i don't believe in collective guilt of
any kind i'm an individual i'll take
responsibility for what i do or what
i've done
i don't like the term privilege
i think it's used way too much i
certainly understand why some struggling
coal miner
when you hear some rich
white kid talk about privilege it's
obnoxious but we do you you will
acknowledge the fact that we you and i
have white privilege i will not i will
call it i will call it advantage have i
had advantages for being white i'm sure
i have that semantics what's the
difference between privilege and
advantage to you
can i explain yeah
[Music]
advantage means like when i was starting
out in the early 80s when we were comics
right
could there have been a moment
where
i was
up against a black comic to get a job at
the chuckle hut in cleveland and the
comedy owner said
okay let's go with the white guy right
because we'll probably do a little more
ticket sales on saturday night i mean
this is 1980 after all right
that could have happened absolutely and
that's not that would be glitch
well
it's an advantage i don't know what
a it's not a privilege
but that's the problem in today's
society a word
uh you know is is the um
or even why we're getting cancelled it's
it's perception over content so the
perception of privilege to you is
different than the perception of
advantage the advantage is when you are
a white guy
and you are pulled over in the middle of
the night
and yes it's an advantage
and i have the privilege of just not
having to worry about being you know my
friends who are well that's not true we
do what i mean this how many people do
you think the police shoot a year
i don't know see so you're talking out
of your ass well tell me a thousand
they shoot about a thousand people a
year okay and how many how many of that
is are white people tell me
so again you we're having the discussion
no but you're you're so sure of yourself
you don't even know the stats but why
does that stat
because you're talking about what you're
talking about how much you have to worry
about not i have to worry my friends who
are black who are raising who are
married and raising kids right here's
what i this is my personal experience my
personal experience when i took my kids
out and they got their driver's license
right i was worried about them driving
safely and and those are the discussions
i have don't speed and don't take
somebody my black friends have to have
an added discussion i agree that i've
never had with my kids if you get pulled
over by the cop make sure that your
hands are there don't reach for anything
okay so isn't that privilege
okay again let's not talk about let's
let's i like the word advantage better
there's something about privilege
that just is
it
it it bleeds into something that gets a
little ridiculous our advantage i think
is a harsher thing
i think it's a realer thing i think you
guys are talking about the same thing
and you don't want to use it because
yeah the connotation of it that's
attached to it
okay but let's get back to the police
okay okay you shoot about a thousand
people a year
right right now in a country of 340
million people
a lot of whom are crazy and a lot of
whom are armed
i don't know if that's like
a ridiculous number
there are some people the police do have
to shoot we'll probably say
white
three quarters
more white wow but
since blacks are only 14 of the
population
that's almost twice the percentage
of what it would be right okay so
there's a problem there's a problem but
police also have many more encounters
with black people
so you have to figure in all these
things you also have to figure out the
disadvantages that lead to
that lead to more people of color living
in poverty living in these situations
where
correct they have worse schooling
there's all these systematic things that
lead to that point i was points i was
making when you were in the crib
i'm not that young okay
okay but i'm just saying i've been all
over this territory forever right you
know it's not like she taught in the
inner city she's not like i'm she's a
teacher from crenshaw yeah of course
there's a
obviously there's a giant legacy of
racism and the horrendous sorry history
of america with race
and that goes into it but when a
policeman is out
where a woman is out doing their job
that doesn't really figure in they're
just dealing with what's going on right
now well listen i every time i see an
officer anywhere but on any set i thank
them for their service i believe
and i think they're incredibly brave and
i think you know the one thing that
we're missing in society and whether
it's to uh
police officers or teachers or friends
or people who have different political
opinions and ideas is we have lost
respect there is no more respect you
don't have to respect you know if you
not like me and you don't think like me
then you're an idiot right you know and
no and back to the police for just for a
second
i think even to this day i think it is
true that black folks do have to worry
more about being stopped and
those are the stats on
who get shot by the police
roughed up in other words put your hands
on people that kind of stuff right that
is way more done to people of color than
white people okay so yes so there is
still
advantage to being white
no doubt buy your work i'll tell you
i'll take away
no doubt about it what i'm always trying
to say is let's just first of all get
the numbers right you know let's not
just pull it out of our ass i didn't put
your numbers out no no i'm just saying
but people do they just have a feeling
about it i mean if you ask the average
msnbc listener right how many
unarmed black people do you think the
police kill a year they'd probably say
50 000 or 10. but do they really have to
have the fact like you've even said now
that you've given us the numbers
somebody with the knowledge well
you're saying if you take the if you do
the calculus you know where you think
what percentage of these people based on
the population
it is a problem
whether i know the number or not it is a
problem yes racism is still a problem in
america it's just a different problem
and a lesser problem than it was 20
years ago 10 years ago certainly 50
years ago i mean we are moving in the
right direction
and if you want to pretend that we're
living in 1973 as a lot of people do i
can't go there with you i i always say
let's live in the year we're living in
i don't think two white guys sitting
here should celebrate where we are on
racism and that's a [ __ ] talking
point also that two white people or
three white people can't have a
discussion about this that that i am not
a sentient being no can i understand
racism as well as a black person of
course not but i i'm not without the
ability to see what's going on in the
world and by the way there's two ways
you can not understand something in
general one by being not close enough to
it yes i'm not as close to it as a black
person and the other way is by being too
close to it people who are too close to
something sometimes
are blind to it as well i mean whoopi
goldberg
said that she thought the holocaust was
not about race
now i defended her right even though she
had attacked me like two weeks earlier
on something else
because i said you know you can't expect
to have treated black people the way
this country has decade after decade
century after century and then not have
them have a completely different view on
race
it's not one i agree with i thought that
was a ridiculous comment the holocaust
wasn't about race
as a jew you must be somewhat offended
by that but it's like i get why she's
coming from that place and she has every
right to say it and she should not it
was just a bad analogy
it wasn't an analogy it was it was a
statement the holocaust was not about
race and but she has the right to feel
that way and i understand why she feels
that way but it would be an example of
someone who maybe is too close to it
right and so doesn't have what i think
is a correct point of view on it and
there's a lot of network that lost
politically incorrect shunder for two
weeks there's lots of ways to uh you
know
not have the right answers
[Music]
you